[Musique]
on connaît déjà l'idée des services de
garde implantés dans des résidences pour
aînés comme c'est le cas ici au ch et
celle des manoirs soleil à chambly qui
abrite une garderie dans ces
institutions intergénérationnel tout
petit et personnes âgées se côtoient au
quotidien échanges et crée des liens le
concept s'applique maintenant à de
jeunes adultes la résidence pour aînés
humanitas en hollande héberge des
étudiants tout à fait gratuitement en
échange ces derniers s'engagent à passer
une trentaine d'heures par mois avec les
résidents l'idée de départ de cet
échange de services surprenant et de
combattre l'isolément social et la
dépression vécue par certaines personnes
âgées en hébergement à cleveland aux
états unis une résidence propose elle
aussi aux aînés de cohabiter avec de
jeunes adultes des étudiants de
l'institut musical de cette ville sont
hébergés sans débourser un sou en
échange de concert pour les résidents
[Musique]